so it's 1969 New York City third grade
music class and our teacher brings us
into a room with nothing but a piano and
chairs and one by one he calls us up and
he plays middle C and he asks us to sing
it said it at a lalalala and you're
either instructed to go to the right
side of the room or the left side of the
room and when all 35 kids are done the
left side of the room which I was a part
of was told to stand up and go back to
homeroom and none of us ever received
another music class again in elementary
school and in club in an out Club was
established and I didn't even know what
the gating test was in the moment few
years later English class first paper of
a first of a new semester and I get the
paper back and it's C+ with the Kermit
good as can be expected now honestly I
didn't mind a C+ I was just happy it
wasn't a c-minus or D but the good as
can be expected comment even at that
young age it didn't seem right it seems
somehow limiting now how many people
here have had an experience similar to
that either at school or the workplace
we're not alone
so I guess it might be ironic that my
life path would lead me to a career of
making music and writing for Blue Man
Group and starting a school but school
was torture for me as someone who didn't
have a natural proclivity for academics
and my teachers never seem to understand
me I didn't know how to navigate schools
and schools didn't know what to do with
me so I started to ask the question even
back then if these environments didn't
know what to do with people who didn't
fit a standard mold why weren't we
reshaping the environments to take
advantage of people's strengths what
I've come to believe is that we need to
cultivate safe and conducive conditions
for new and innovative ideas to evolve
and thrive we know that humans are
innately innovative because if we
weren't we'd all be using the same
arrowheads that we were using 10,000
years ago so one of the things that I
started to question is are there ways to
make innovation easier and happen more
frequently is there a way to take those
aha moments those breakthroughs that
seem to happen randomly and occasionally
and have them happen intentionally and
frequently when we started Blue Man
Group in 1988 we had never done an
off-broadway show before we'd actually
done almost no theatre but we knew what
we were passionate about and it was a
whole series of things that we had never
seen on stage before things like art and
pop culture and technology and sociology
and anthropology and percussion and
comedy and and following your bliss
we established a rule that nothing made
it on stage if we had seen it before and
we wanted to inspire creativity and
connectedness in ourselves and our
audiences we wanted to do a little bit
of social good and we wanted to have fun
doing it and in the office we wanted to
create an environment where people
treated each other just in a little bit
better just a little bit more respect
and consideration than in the outside
world and we continued to iterate and
collaborate and find solutions to create
things that hadn't been seen over time
I've come to identify the optimal
conditions for these types of creative
and innovative environments our clear
intent purpose and passion this is
working on something bigger than
ourselves personal integrity it's doing
what we say we're going to do it's being
our authentic self in all interactions
direct communication and clear
expectations even when the subject
matter is difficult grit and
perseverance iteration iteration
iteration establish collaborative teams
instill deep trust and mutual respect
everyone on your team is in there is no
out Club we rise as a team we fall as a
team and decisions are decisions until
they're not embrace multiple
perspectives
this means all voices matter all
emotions matter address disagreements
head-on people should feel seen and
heard take risks and celebrate mistakes
a commitment to being a learning
organization always trying to spiral
upwards the innovation and learning
curves and speak in one voice this is
perhaps the glue that holds all these
conditions together
the concept is that we speak in the
exact same manner about someone who's
not in the room as if they are in the
room now this seems basic but it's an
aspirational practice that helps deal
with difficult situations in a more
respectful way sewing this practice in
can have a profound effect on raising
the bar on mutual respect trust reducing
gossip and politics in the office and
the classroom and thus reducing the
noise that gets in the way of the
innovative process at Blue Man Group
iteration was essential for our creative
process we were writing a piece where we
were trying to illustrate the
consumption waste loop in a funny and
creative and surprising way for our
audiences now if you have yourselves
thought about trying to do the same
endeavor I can save you a lot of time
right here and now I can definitively
tell you that oatmeal
jello Cream of Wheat dak pudding clay
tapioca silly putty and tomato paste do
not slide through a tube that's coiled
up under your costumes that's meant to
come out an orifice in your chest and
spray towards the audience it won't
happen
after months of iteration we finally
happened upon bananas who knew that
bananas would have the exact right
properties to stay solid even with push
through a tube with forced air yet
slippery enough to have the dramatic
losing effect that we were looking for
this piece became a signature of the
Blue Man Show we in throw out all the
rules of theater altogether we had set
designs we had lighting designs we had a
stage manager calling the show but I'm
fairly sure we were one of the very
first shows that was connecting with our
audience in a respectful way by hanging
them upside down dipping them in paint
slamming them against the canvas putting
their heads in seventy pounds of jell-o
and then making them one of the heroes
of the show besides that we didn't
reinvent what didn't need to be
reinvented years later we took all this
learning and we've created a school a
school for our children that we wish we
had gone to a school where it was just
as important what happened in the
hallways between classes as what
happened in the classes a place where
you got music class even when you
couldn't sing middle C at blue school
teachers and parents and students are
equal collaborators at the table
intentionally creating a safe space
where they can develop a lifelong joyful
passion for learning again we didn't try
to reinvent
the wheel when it didn't need to be
reinvented we don't shy away from a more
traditional methods like direct
instruction when it's the best way into
a lesson but we balance it with an
integrated learning across all subjects
approach and balance is the key
in fact blue school was founded on a
balance between academic mastery
creative thinking and self and social
intelligence I realize that this might
sound like common sense but in some
circles this is and these qualities have
brought a lot of attention to blue
school as a truly innovative school
nearly 10 years in we announced the
expansion of a middle school our faculty
asked our sixth graders to participate
in the development of middle school
values their process began with the
question what do you need from our
community to be happy and productive at
school students move through a six-week
process of individual work collaborative
work refinement and consensus and the
list they came up with is really
extraordinary be engaged and present
with each other respect and support what
others need in order to learn be
inclusive of our diversity the way we
look think and act cultivate the
practice of self awareness and awareness
of others honor and make time for fun
and joy and challenge ourselves practice
being okay making mistakes and support
each other through them remember
these kids were 11 years old when they
came up with this they articulated what
took us 20 years to identify one of the
great byproducts of creating these
vibrant communities is that we become a
tractors for people who want to
prioritize these values they want to
prioritize it above things like money
and prestige and tradition we can all be
on this road together you with your own
values in your own companies in your own
communities and families for us for me
it was about prioritizing children's
voices to give them the tools to help
build a harmonious and sustainable world
I invite you to be on this exciting
passionate joyful journey together and
together good as can be expected is
limitless when the expectation is that
by reshaping our environments we can
change the world thank you
[Applause]